c'est l'heure du débat on va revenir sur
cette condamnation qui a fait énormément
réagir tiens deux hommes qui avaient
insulté et fait des doigts d'honneur au
président Emmanuel Macron lors d'un bain
de fou la célesttin en avril dernier ont
été condamnés à 100 et 200 € d'amende
donc voilà donc pour les doigts
d'honneur tout ça c'est 100 et 200 €
d'amende ça fait beaucoup réagir fa
courir dans le public alors si certains
trouvent la sanction beaucoup trop
faible contenu qu'il s'agit du du
président de la République d'autres
trouvent ça abusé de condamner des gens
pour entre guillemets si peu euh nous on
a pris 3 millions et demi d'amende euh
avec Louis Boyard qui est juste
président exactement qui est juste
président du fort
voilà allez regardez les images du bain
de fou la céesta c'était le 19 avril
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez on veut pas de ta retraite
qu'est-ce que tu comprends pas làdedans
on n veut
pas non mais on veut pas du cul je
voulais juste serrer la main à un
président qui a un gouvernement aussi
corrompu on vous demande une seule chose
c'est un signe d'apaisement et là
vraiment on le voit pas
télion télision alors 100 et 200 €
d'amende pour avoir insulté fait des
doigs d'honneur à Emmanuel Macron
comprenez-vous cette décision vous avez
des pancartes c'est pas pour qu'elle
reste sur les trucs les chéis merci euh
comprenez-vous cette décision non Gill
vous trouvez que c'est trop clément ah
non je trouve que c'est beaucoup trop
sévère moi j'éta pour qu'il pas de peine
bon moi je me barre allez ça y est je me
barre aussi non mais je te moi je peux
plus bien moi je me bar non mais sérieux
moi je vais me barrer moi je vais me
barrer moi je vais me barrer non mais
sérieux je vais me barrer arrête arrête
quoi toi tu trouves que 100 et 200 €
d'Amand pour avoir fait des doigts
d'honneur il dire trou du cul au
Président c'est c'est c'est c'est pas
c'est c'est trop mais c'est un scandale
il fallait qu'il y ait pas de peine il
fallait qu'il y a une dispense de peine
c'est ridicule c'était au moment de la
promulgation de la loi sur les retraites
les gens étaient excités dans le cadre
d'une foule des gens s'expriment pour
moi c'est la libre expression il y a
plus de délit au chef de l'État ça
n'existe plus donc pour moi ces gens
auraient dû être exonérés de PE je vous
le dis ne rien recevoir du tout ni
amende ni blame ni sanction rien voilà
même pas jugé s'il vous plaît non mais
en fait moi je trouve que la sanction
elle est tellement dérisoire elle est
tellement sy me fa rien mettre
raison a même du surc je crois donc en
fait c'est ridicule effectivement la
l'amende elle est juste symbolique mais
elle ne sert à rien mais moi je pense
qu'il faut quand même marquer le coup g
sous prétexte que voilà il y a gens sont
contexte d'un bain de foule j'ai le
contexte d'un bain de foule c'est pas
comme si on
interromp la République à ce momentlà
alors alors à ce moment-là on va
inventer des bains de foule et quand il
y aura des bains de foule on fera des
doigts d'honneur on s'insultera à ce
moment-là on dit aux enfants dans les
écoles benah je sais pas il faut
respecter l'autorité respecter les profs
ça bah non non non on est un bain de fou
on est une classe on s'en fout on fait
des doigts d'honneur au profs c'est
comme tous se perd aujourd'hui il y a
plus du tout d'autorité moi je pense que
malgré tout c'est un en fait c'est un
bon signal ridicule voilà les deux en
même temps il faut qu'ils soit
responsable ces gens-là ils sont pas
c'est pas des gamins C des gens ok on
peut comprendre la colère des grèves des
retraites on comprend 100 ou 200 € c'est
pas non plus ça été 3 4000 € j'aurais
été révolté j'ais c'est n'importe quoi
mais sils avaient fait ça un policier
s'il avaient fait ça à quelqu'un d'autre
ils auraient été condamnés aussi peut
pas dire à ton président de ta France
c'est un vote qu'on aime ou qu'on aime
pas Onon aime ou qu'on aime pas c'est le
président qui a été élu tu fais pas des
doigts d'honneur tu lui mets pas des
gifes tu fais pas des trucs comme ça
c'est les institutions il y aura les
votes tu vas au vote et tu votes mais
100 200 € pour moi voilà c'est fallait
faire quelque chose tu peux pas rester
sans rien faire vous êtes tout le temps
en train de parler dans les autres pays
regardez comment ça se passe dans les
autres pays va faire ça dans les autres
pays c'est pas 100 ou 200 € que tu vas
prendre ma mère elle me dit j'ai 440 €
mois d'amende et voilà parce qu'elle a
insulté un mec qui m'avait mal parlé sur
facebook bah oui non mais ah ouais elle
a été commissariat et touttit Conti he
ah ouais et ouais 440 balles d'amende
par c'est ma mère faut pas la faire
chier coup de Bou
direct il a en
plus c'est vrai oui oui j'espère que
quand le président va à la rencontre des
Français comme ça c'est pour prendre la
température pour savoir un peu ce que
pense la population si à ce point s'il
veut que des compliments on prend des on
prend des une assemblé
de différence entre des compliments et
trou du
C a vouu empêcher les casseroles c'était
des amendes et nuisance sonore
maintenant on empêche de raller contre
le président on
va cerol les casseroles fallait pas
empêcher c'est Pacifique je suis
d'accord avec toi non trou du cul et des
do donneur non c'est pas les C je
comprends tout à
fait
bien une manifestation avec les
policiers il y a les gens qui font des
doigts d'honneur et qui insultent les
policiers trouv ça normal les policiers
ont rien à
voir le patron tu r contre le patron tu
r
contre dans une entreprise quand ton
patron voir va dire demain moi je va
arriver et tu vas comme ça trou du
cul c'est qu'il y a dans les piquets de
grve
etis demain l n'importe quoi mais non
demain ne me tentez pas c'est le demain
vas- plaisir sans compter que ma mère va
t'appeler 40 fois pour te
défoncer une amende alors vous allez
faire des degrés alors si on fait juste
ou on va avoir 10 balle si ou c'est rien
du tout tu as le droit de huer tu as
droit de le huer le président mais tu as
pas le droit de
l'insulter mais c'est qui qu'on soit
d'accord ou qu'on soit pas d'accord avec
sa politique qu'on soit d'accord ou
qu'on soit pas d'accord c'est qui ce ce
gars là c'est le président la républque
pas attend déjà ce sera moi le
me je
su on est danste très particulier qui
est un contteù il a des manifestations
partout cont des Français ça h dans T
les je suis pas du tout d'accord AC
Val vori excusez-moi Valérie vous êtes
vous êtes aussi nul que Gill sur ce
débat moi je trouve que ce qui ressort
de ça c'est qu'on a pas le droit de
critiquer le président en fait on fait
une B on est condamné on dit une insulte
pardon mais c'est bon enfant c'est pas
c'est pas d'une violence
extrême arrête moi j'adore moi j'adore
ça quand on me de trou du cul c'est ce
que je préfère et c'est des insultes
qu'on voit alors malheureusement et et
qu'on entend à longueur de temps dans la
rue sur les réseaux sociaux la voilà de
là condamné ça et ça donne quand même le
sentiment d'avoir une justice à de
vitesse là on condamne dès qu'il y a la
moindre insulte c'est jugé condamné
immédiatement et à côté de ça on a des
mecs qui menac qui frappe qui insulte et
qui n'ont rien donc
cohér oui symboliquement ça envoie un
signalésmanuel Macron aime beaucoup
aller à ce qu'on appelle àorter de BAFF
donc il va au contact de la population
c'est vrai que ça réagit fortter de BAFF
devzess j'ai déjà testé mais c'est pas
la première fois il se fait souvent
souvent insulter mais peut-être que là
moi bon je comprends qu'à un moment stop
curseés le curseur c'est quoi si on a le
droit de dire TR du cul au président si
on a le droit de lui faire des doigts
d'honneur à boutort c'est quoi la suite
est-ce que j'ai le droit de lui dire va
te faire est-ce que j'ai droit de lui
dire à ta femme machin je est-ce que
j'ai le droit de
dire
j'ai pour pas
[Applaudissements]
Dr raison pas on pas trop du président
même si Monsieur voilà on comprend il é
énervé mais tu dis pas trop Président je
suis désolé 100 et 200 € d'amende une
rigolarrêter je vous dis ma mère elle
insulté un mec elle a pris 44 € d'amende
arrêtez de dire des conneries mais ce
que vous dites c'est qu'il aurait dû
prendre plus moi j'ai plus j'ai plus ou
plus ou rien non c'était bien comme ça
moi j'ai plus de mal avec le mec l'avion
là quand il met Macron en destitution
qu'on le fasse chez lui je m'en fous moi
en fait lu il risqu 15000 € d'AM dérange
s' 200 balles et un an de prison et un
an de prison pour ça la peine maximale
c'est oui bah oui mais c'est un an de
prison 15000 € voilà Ilis ball voilà
exactement donc mais autant lui donner
rien c'est ça vous dit vous dites plus
ou rien c toi toi est ce que tu penses
non mais arrête avec ça et je te pose
une question toi est-ce que tu penses
qu'il aurait dû être sanctionné non mais
non rien zé P pouroi par de mais parce
que c'est la libre expression de gens
mécontents dans une France exaspérée on
a le droit en tant que président de la
République symbole de l'institution on a
le droit de l'insulter si on est
exaspéré sin on
pas quand nous quand nous ici on vient
tout seul on n pas Président nous on est
rien on est chroniqueur on vient tout
seul ici faire les guignol à se maqu
pourquoi quand on se fait menacer
certains ici qui se font menacer de mort
qui se font insulter pourquoi vous allez
porter PL pourquoi vous allez porter PL
ilul il y a des insulte pourquoi vous
allez porter plainte quand c'est vous et
pourquoi vous voulez pas que lui qui est
le président il laisse passer des trucs
comme ça le curseur est où je répète le
curseur est oùul
[Applaudissements]
jus pas comp à
comprendre'
plaî face de paix mais non
mais non mais il a raison il a raison
insulter tout le monde on va le faire il
a entièrement raison Raymon qui a envie
de se faire insulter de cette façon
personne il faut insulter personne
pourquoias parce que je trouve que je
comprends la décision de marquer le coup
mais qu façon de marquer mais c'est rien
c'est symbolique c'est de marquer le
coup bien sûr parce qu'on ninsulte pas
ni le président ni qui que ce soit envie
qu'on trait de trou du cul dans la rue
toi mais pourquoi tu mets non parce que
je comprends les
décisionam tu as rien compris tais-toi
eh vous êtes bouché ou quoi j'ai compris
la décisionendê précieux pour dire trois
conneries donc tais-toi fait comme
d'habitude je pas il a pas tort mais non
je comprends mais non mais
c'est excuse-moi mais non il a été ils
ont été condamnés je comprends qu'on
condamne c'est bon c'est bon merci oui
et pour moi ce sera quoi qu'est-ce
qu'elle
a comme tu as appelé Bernard je peux pas
insulter même pour rigoler je n'y arrive
et bien moi je voulais dire que je
trouve ça super 200 € c'est très bien
parce que moins c'est pas possible de
pas marquer le coup par c'est uneivilité
et plus on va pas faire 2000 5000 € on
va pas faire de
l'ISE donc 200 € c'est très bien c'est
comme un bon excès de vitesse il aurait
pas dû faire ça et 200 € c'est très
bien y a quand même des gens fait qui
ont le droit d'insulter don ils n' pas
le droit d'insulter quand on met charlio
quand on met Macron déit en alors ils
ont une
AM liberté de la press liber d'accord
par que les arstes pressoit d'
mais c'est pas c'était des artistes mais
qu'est-ce que tu racontes c'éta des
gens non non là tu gué
la av il aensé à pernikov pas
bien 65 % merci pour une fois que les
gens sont B c'est bien pour une fois que
tu gagnes un
truc allez